thank you for the questions and I'm here
my office in Stockholm and I'm going to
answer them one by one but many of you
actually put several questions so then I
had to pick one of them the first one is
from number one what in your mind is the
number one lesson to be learned from
your way of looking at data what ought
our governments do with that they are
not doing well it's clearly to
collaborate better the world is coming
together whether you call it
globalization or whatever and we need
the better global governance and by the
end of the year the first test for a
hope for change is the climate
negotiations in Copenhagen let's see if
we will do better than last time
number two Reuben sandwich if you could
present your stats to a panel of any
five people in the world who would you
choose and why
oh that's an easy one I would choose
president Lula President Putin president
Jintao Prime Minister Singh and
President Zuma that is the leaders of
Brazil Russia China India and South
Africa the leading emerging economies
and the middle-income countries that
today constitute about three billion of
mankind half mankind I think those are
the most important leaders because they
must on one hand established good and
productive relations with a high-income
countries that were used to determine
everything in this world and on the
other hand they have to act decently and
make good investment in the poorest
countries the investments from China and
India and Brazil in the poorest
countries in Africa are very hopeful if
they are managed correctly so it's those
future leader of the world from the big
nations that I would love to present
number three Universal sprout asks in my
experience people do not understand
statistics and will never change their
opinion based on statistics I would like
to ask if you agree no I do
but statistics has to go together with
other information and with experience
that's when it's useful I'll give you
one example if I search Google in the
United States for unemployment rate this
is result and if I click in the one box
here I will get a new type of graphic
showing the unemployment rate for United
States from 1990 and onwards today to an
all-time high on 9.7% I think most
people the United States understand this
curve because it relates to them and
they are very keen to see whether it
will turn around and they would also
like to see how the unemployment have
hit different parts of the countries so
they can go here and they would look for
California and see that California today
actually has a higher unemployment than
the average of the country it's all the
way up to twelve point one and and some
of you perhaps or perhaps are interested
of Silicon Valley so then we open
California here we go down to Santa
Clara County and Santa Clara County look
historically they were lower than the
average in the 90s but in the dot-com
bubble burst in 2002 unemployment rate
skyrocketed to nine point one percent
but today it is higher you see
if you present and make statistics
accessible in this way then many will
start to use it and it will be very
interesting now to get the August
figures for United States as a whole and
the different countries to see whether
the present crisis have come to a
plateau or whether it is already
starting to go down or continuing to
rise people are not stupid they'll
understand statistics and they will use
it if it's made available in in relevant
and interesting ways number four rags
seven to nine asks what is
the most startling or intriguing
correlation you have been counted by
playing with different values on the X
and y axis at gapminder.org well it's
not really the correlation but it is
what we can do with animation the trends
the change of a time that has been most
startling to me and the fact that the
middle-income countries are catching up
so fast let me show you a classical
example here in Gapminder world I show
total fertility rate on this axis I show
life expectancy on this axis and 1800
United States had an estimate these are
rough historical estimate of seven
children per woman and the life
expectancy was just a 39-year those were
rough time and if I move United States
forward what really happens was that
family size started to decline and with
industrialization life expectancy
started to increase it got better and
better progress in medical science and
health service and after the first world
war and off to the Second World War that
was a baby boom and that was 1950 1950
United States had about three children
per woman and 68 years typical for part
of the Western world
now I'll compare that with Vietnam which
I find down here that's where Vietnam
was 1950 and I'll compare it with Iran
two prominent middle-income countries
with special relationships to the United
States and I could say quite reliable
data I know the professionals in these
two countries personally that are
compiling this data so Vietnam had five
children per woman and 39 years like
United States 150 years ago Iran 1950
was almost like
200 years ago in United States and now
come my message look how they have
catched up in the last 50 years they
relive the lost 25 years they have
catched up like this and today they are
just about one younger Asian Xavier
narration of the United States when it
comes to size of family and length of
life
this is what I've amazed me more that
really the world is converging as EF
Sachs says it is getting more and more
similar by this middle three billion
people when it comes to human resources
and family life they are catching up
this surprised me when I got the data so
clear in front of me
number five [ __ ] John what do you think
of the state of statistics education in
high school and college well I can't
think so much because I don't know it in
detail but I have a hope and that is
that the ability to play computer games
and the ability to develop interesting
tools in flash can now be used in school
but an obstacle is that many schools
block the downloading and installing of
of Flash readers so there must be
another attitudes in school so that
students and teachers can access freely
the Internet
let there be flash in schools and
statistics will be found number six
Garrus scarcity would you be willing to
help the white house presently
healthcare budget in such a way as to
make it easier for the average person to
understand the value of public option or
a single-payer plan well I'm willing but
I don't know if I'm able because there's
been a blockage in the United States
regarding discussion of the health
system let me show you a graph look at
this graph at the horizontal axis I show
health spending per person in purchasing
power dollars that is comparable dollars
between countries the size of each
bubble is the size of the population of
the countries
and here we have life expectancy the
length of life the owl come of health
service and there is a color here also
showing something it is the percent of
the gross national product that is used
for health service the United States is
hot and red with 15% of the national
income being used for health service all
other countries in the world use less
for health service except one little
friend of the United States down there
which one is this it's East Timor
there's only two countries in the world
that use more than fifteen percent of
the national income for health service
United States and East Timor stands out
as an exception but neither of the two
managed to achieve especially good
health in relation to the investment and
and and we are also surprised outside
the United States that that that
President Obama's health plan is
regarded as communist or socialist
United States can compare with a country
like Switzerland Switzerland use 11
percent of its national gross national
product for health and they achieve 82
years of life expectancy United States
use 15% and we achieve 78 years the
United States you don't have to do like
like Mike Moore and compare United
States with Cuba there's so many
countries today that use much less money
for health but to achieve the same
result here chilla here Costa Rica here
Singapore here South Korea here Portugal
and down here we have Denmark the many
many countries that use less money with
the same result and it's range United
States that is such a competitive
country so good in sport so
intrapreneurial
so good in film and everything it seems
United States don't want to compete in
in health care it must be very sad to be
the lost
the world in using dollar well for
health I think this notion has to change
in the population of the United States
but I don't know if I'm the person to
help in that if I could I will number
seven playin asks do you think CUDA is
an important step in the path of better
and richer visualization of data but
their player and look at me do I look
like a person who know what CUDA is I
never heard the term but I look like a
person sixty one-year-old who can write
codes I've never written code people
have given me credit for developing
software where I only have expressed the
need for the software and had been a
keen user the gap behind the software
was developed by my son and his wife and
a growing team of flesh developers in
Sweden that are now moved to Google and
now I work together with another team
here in Gapminder foundation that
developed the stuff that I use in the
lectures and don't give too much credit
of older males you know they often
hasn't done everything you think they've
done pepper what are your future plans
for Gapminder it is very clear to
maintain the users we have and continue
with a steady increase but also
specifically to develop tools that are
suitable for teachers and students in
education later this year we will add a
part of our webpage called for teachers
and there you will get goodies that you
can use in education regarding the major
global development trends make that
Gospel known around the world that
Gapminder will provide stuff for schools
number nine border groves asks what can
be done to encourage governments and
international organizations to more
actively and effectively collect and
publish vital statistics it's easy the
World Bank the OECD the FAO the IMF
should do as President Obama is doing he
nominated the chief information officer
Vivek Kundra that started the site
data.gov and made the data freely
available in both visualization and this
is important as data set that could be
freely downloadable in relatively
uniform format and and totally machine
readable so that others companies civil
society organizations could innovate and
make the data available for special
groups in new visual ways this is a way
to go forward let the data that has been
paid for by tax payers be freely
available in ways that complement what
government is doing with the data then a
fad like Buddha but how do you recommend
that I or we help the bottom billion I'm
wondering about practical ways the top
billion can assist the bottom billion
with a small unit of organization well
it's good that you're using the new term
bottom billions that was launched by
Paul Collier the professor of economics
in Oxford in this book and I strongly
recommend you to also read paul cole
years lost book sometimes you have to
read books also not only read it and and
and Ted videos Paul Collier has written
Wars guns and votes this is real about
the poorest 1 billion people in the
world
let me show on these graphics who they
are this is income per person in dollars
per day and and this was 1970 what has
happened in the world is that population
has grown
and many people have moved out of
poverty but just a little bit and now in
2008 this is more or less where the
world is the bottom billion is the
people living here still on less than
one dollar a day and many of them are
living in civil war like in Afghanistan
Somalia or in very fragile states that
are almost falling down into civil wars
on the other side of the line you find
countries like Tanzania Zambia Cambodia
that has come out of the poverty and now
start to move on that's another
situation and then here in the middle
you find what we call middle-income
economies like Vietnam Egypt and Peru
that are not doing well and are
progressing forward but with great
inequity still within countries now you
need different forms of support for
different companies the bottom billion
need humanitarian aid so the answer my
question is red cross medicines on
frontier and similar humanitarian
organization on one hand on the other
hand wise and careful security operation
led by the United Nations those have to
be combined and then help good national
leaders to move their countries into a
more stable situation that has happened
in countries like Mozambique in Cambodia
and when we come on the other side of
this line then microcredits becomes more
important but also long-term aid for
health like vaccinations for education
for infrastructure and then countries
must have a fair trade situation in the
world
so humanitarian aid on this side
microcredits on this side and support to
education health and infrastructure
number-10 be stranger to love what's it
like knowing so many on reddit have
intense nerd crushes on you it's
wonderful but it's also a challenge it's
mainly a challenge how can we make
information about the
world even better available and how can
we reach the many with what we have
already succeeded with this is what we
are trying now with a small team at
Gapminder foundation we try to do our
best and we are very interesting to get
your comments and to have your help to
let more people know about our services
thank you very much